you
we have just had a moment of very big
excitement here in the Bell forum in
Seoul ah outside Stockholm this year's
prize in physiology or medicine has just
been announced and now there are two
very happy guys and a lot of
disappointed researchers all over the
world of course and should we start
Jelena Surratt with the what have you
awarded this year so this year we've
awarded the Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine to John B girden in Shinya
Yamanaka for the discovery that adult
cells can become very potent yeah that
is really a huge discovery I mean it's
scattered a lot of the scientific world
when you realize that that the skin cell
for example could be turned back into
his cell that could do almost anything I
mean nobody would believe you if to
serve this like 50 years ago well
certainly that was I imagine surprising
that the cell has the ability to back up
from a mature State to an immature state
yeah
because we've been used to seeing these
like a development in a river only runs
one way or yeah or a tree or whatever
you're telling and it can only go in one
direction and then these two guys
discover that this is not true which is
often the case of course in science that
you this time that all our truths are
not truth at all that's the beauty of
silence
but tell me first if you take John be
golden he said he done research with a
rather ugly frog if I should say so it's
a frog that lives in the water in Africa
what has he done with his father so what
he did was he took the cell of a young
frog immature cell in embryo cell and he
took out the nucleus from that cell and
he replaced that with the nucleus from a
mature tadpole and what he found was
that manipulated cell could develop into
a normal tadpole a swimming tadpole so
the DNA retained all the information to
develop the cells of a temple and this
is many years ago it's like in the late
50s or even $67 he must be very sort of
almost well brave and almost mad to do
this kind of research certainly we could
consider him up higher in a pioneer and
that discovery was published in 1962 so
it was 50 years ago and then comes our
other lawyer who is doing him even more
advanced thing he takes a skin cell from
a mouse and he treated it with some
genes and he found out that he takes
only like four genes to make the skin
cell what we could now called
pluripotent but his which me really
needs that it can do a lot of different
things right so he was really interested
in genes that confer pluripotency
cells and so you're correct he
identified four genes that he could put
into these cells and when he did that
the skin cell from a mouse became an
immature cell so it became pluripotent
of course this is not only for to play
around this is a
a lot of serious and they have a lot of
serious goals with this one of them
lives of course medical if you can get
cells like this you could use them to
treat a lot of big diseases big and
common diseases well I think we could
say that their discoveries really our
basic science they haven't translated
that to the clinic but what we can see
is that because of their work who are at
the forefront of examining these
technologies for potential clinical
application and so you're right that
there is research into how one can
utilize these IPS cells at least
inducible pluripotent stem cells to be
able to reprogram into different cell
types or new cell types that could be
used to either study disease mechanisms
for example neural cells are very
difficult to get from patients with this
technology one can develop neural cells
in a culture dish and study them
potentially down the line way down the
line this might be a clinical
application but at least today it's too
early to say this discovery is used in
the clinic at this day yeah with one
exception and that is of course the use
of stem cells in blood that had be used
for many years to treat special and
cancer diseases yeah it's not actually
induced pluripotent stem cells so that
was an idea of how stem cell therapy can
be used as regenerative medicine to help
cure or treat disease yeah and this
linger a while on that side yet how to
use this cell because these would of
course saw a lot of yummy neurological
problems you would not get a reaction
from them patient if he got his own cell
or her own cell you could take your skin
cell for example from me and treat my
parking son or my daddy niece or
anything and
how far away is this kind of
redevelopment you think I think that
there's certainly our challenges ahead
with this it's not at the point where
next year we'll have a new therapy for
this kind of treatment but the idea that
one can utilize IPS technology or that
we can understand that a cell a mature
cell can back to an immature state opens
up a whole new frontier of research
which down the line may lead to new
treatments for different diseases like
Parkinson's or cardiovascular defects
liver regeneration insulin producing
cells and diabetes but today we're not
at that stage we're really here with a
discovery that's a fundamental cell
physiology when they made the disk and
of discovery did their colleagues
believe them I mean when it comes to
groundbreaking parody gifts people are
usually not believed in the first place
did the scientific community believe
well certainly the discovery by girden
was met with skepticism uh-huh but
others repeated his work and of course
as with all science once many other
groups start to find the same result of
course people feel confident that if
it's real that's the real not none of
this research is done of course as
always with Laos but what about human
skin cells could you turn them back the
idea he used a mouse and he took skin
cells from the mouse and he could
introduce some genes into the mouse and
he could make them immature cells so of
course one can use human cells how's it
been done there are research efforts
into that area
of course it also solves an ethical
problem because when we talked about
stem cells early days it was only stem
cells that you could get from abortions
and now you could take yourself for I
guess almost any man and use from you
you get away from all this ethical
discussion about abortion theoretically
one can take cells from skin and
actually Rick you know do the same thing
you're bringing up an issue of the
ethical debate yeah and I think the idea
that one can use skin cells from an
adult either an animal or a human would
would lessen the ethical concerns but
one can also imagine there may be
ethical issues there as well yeah so all
scientists need to act responsible with
their discoveries in application of work
yeah so finally how do you reach them
they are happy of course you're on
Hanson has had a telephone conversation
with both Gloria oh and what he tells me
is that Yamanaka was home with his
family
oh and of course he was very happy and
John Gurdon was in the laboratory ronnie
probably running some experiments of
course he was delighted as well okay
you